I want to start with a question what
would you do if you had 250 trillion
dollars I'm sure there are many things
you would do with that sort of money but
what if I told you those 250 trillion
dollars were from Zimbabwe well that's a
totally different question because in
250 trillion Zimbabwean dollars were
worth the equivalent of one u.s. dollar
yeah you heard that absolutely right the
truth is the Zimbabwe is like Venezuela
but on a massive scale this country has
suffered the worst hyperinflation of all
time since more or less the year 2000
prices were rising higher and higher at
an absolutely mind-boggling rate in 2008
a piece of bread was worth 10,000
Zimbabwean dollars and now you know you
wanna drink well
how did all of this happen no answer
it's pretty simple one day Robert Mugabe
told his finance minister dude I don't
care how you do it but man we need money
and what did the finance minister do
well he just pressed the money printing
button like there was no tomorrow
so in conclusion Zimbabwe had to get rid
of their own national currency and led
to the economy be dominated by foreign
currencies especially the American
dollar
but all of this was a little while ago
so what exactly is going on in Zimbabwe
now well in recent days and we're
recording this in 2017 the country
appeared on the noose because of a coup
d'etat that spells the end of Mugabe's
37 year long dictatorship and yes my
difference of visual politic we must say
that coup d'etat are not what they used
to be this was what we could call the
diet coke version of a coup d'etat just
have a look at this Robert Mugabe to get
ten million dollar payoff and immunity
for his family
in fact this coup d'etat could sort of
be better described as a soap opera Maga
be as 93 years old wanted to die in
power and he also wanted his wife who's
52 years old to inherit the presidency
you know the sort of thing that could
only happen in countries like Argentina
North Korea or perhaps the National
Front in France so as you can imagine a
lot of people did not agree with this
so the Mugabe clan sent all of their
political opponents out of the country
this is what happened at the beginning
of November 2017 when they kicked out
the vice presidents and this guy has a
really difficult to pronounce name I
looked it up I still can't pronounce it
properly but his name is Emerson Managua
WA so yes sorry if I butchered the
pronunciation of his name in this one
the Army's reaction to this was
immediate and well you probably know the
rest of the story but now the questions
about Zimbabwe future are many is men
and grab the new Mugabe is this man able
to resurrect Zimbabwe economy today well
we are going to answer those questions
but before we do let's take a look back
at the history the 2000 effect yes you
are right Zimbabwe's economy is a total
disaster and I know what you're thinking
if you make a cocktail where you mix
dictatorship and Africa what you guess
is corruption and poverty right when you
are kinds of right but probably not as
much as you might think in fact there
was a time where Zimbabwe was known as
the African jewel their fertile soil
allowed this country to become as a
whole continents bond and I you might be
wondering well what happened to a
country with so many natural resources
so many rich lands so many gold mines
what caused it to become such a
catastrophe well we also that it
definitely has a name and that name is
Robert Mugabe Zimbabwe has been an
independent country for some 37 years
and 37 years is the amount of time that
Mugabe has been in power the de
colonialization process of the so-called
South Rhodesia or a British colony ended
in a 15-year Civil War
on the one hands we had the wise
minority that made up just five percent
of the population despite what you might
think they didn't have the support of
Western powers they declared their
independence unilaterally and therefore
no other country supported them on the
other hand you have the guerrilla troops
led by Robin and Guardian the man who
combined anti imperialist nationalism
with a hardcore communist knew back then
Margaret Thatcher was the UK's Prime
Minister and you might now be thinking
cold war plus the communist leader plus
Margaret Thatcher sounds like a pretty
explosive combination right well you are
absolutely wrong
back then the UK's priority was to let
their former colonies become healthy
democracies and this is why I herself
signed the peace agreements with the
Zimbabwean guerrilla fighters and
organised elections in the country these
elections were as fair as they could be
given that the country had just ended a
civil war and had guerrilla warriors all
over the place and who won the election
well of course it's Robin and Garvey so
now you might be wondering well did
Mugabe cheat in this election or was it
a fair victory well the evidence
actually suggests that yes he had the
support and yes he did genuinely win the
election
you see among the majority of the black
population in Zimbabwe there are two
major ethnic groups
yeah the Shona who make up 80% of the
population and then you have the matter
Billy who are just 10% well Robin the
Garvey belongs to the Shona group and
this is why it's no surprise that he won
60 percent of the vote
so in 1980 the UK granted independence
to Rhodesia and this is housed in Bob
way became a sovereign country with
Mugabe as the President and during the
first seven years he basically grabbed
all of the power and in terms of the
economy at least we got to admit that
things actually work least in the
beginning
Regardie respected the property rights
of the white population but in a very
Venezuelan fashion he spent all of the
savings from the colonial times and
while we have to admit that although it
didn't work in the long run
Mugabe did achieve a great goal and his
role as in Bob we achieved the highest
literacy rate in Africa
90% of Zimbabwe ins can read and write
so if you've got your dictatorial to-do
list in front of you well what's the
next thing on it well that's to get rid
of the Opposition in this chapter of
maga B's life he did not save a penny
he sends the fifth garrison of his army
to North Korea so that he could learn
about state-of-the-art methods for
oppression and when those soldiers came
back he pretty much said to them all
right guys now go get rid of those
natter bellies wipe them out this is how
the Goroka hundy started karoku condi
means in the shona language early rain
that cleans the straws by the inside
before the spring rain comes yep shown
as they are pretty poetic but despite
the pretty name this was an ethnic
cleansing that was done pretty much as
the manual described and more than
20,000 people died
and with this Mugabi games a great deal
of political stability for had killed
all of his political foes but in the
year 2000 things they really changed
that year Mugabe decided to start an
agricultural revolution in the style of
chairman now it was a real revolution
and everything changed for the worse
gobby decided that the best lands
shouldn't be owned by the white minority
so he expropriated that land and gave it
to surprise surprise his ministers and
political allies however he only gave
them the lands he could not give them
the knowledge to tend it so production
fell sharply while hyperinflation
destroyed the rest of the industries
since then Zimbabwe has pretty much been
a living hell the time of the crocodile
they say crocodiles wait beneath the
water just showing their eyes and their
nostrils until the victim appears then
they open their jaws and they eat them
this is why the new president of
Zimbabwe AMISOM Mann ungawa is known as
the crocodile Mullen gawe was one of
those guerrilla leaders during the civil
war and he has been a minister since
1980 so he spent all of his life waiting
under the shadow of the dictator but his
moment has finally come so far after
this coup his first steps they've been a
very risky here is an example
Zimbabwe leaders cabinet heavy on
military ruling party but this is not
enough as in Bob Way and he still has a
lot of work ahead but one of the biggest
steps has already been taken
government amend in digitisation law the
indigenisation law is another economic
policy made by Mugabe
in this case he said bigger companies
couldn't belong to white people as you
can imagine the white minority that used
to live in the country has already
emigrated they used to be 5% of the
population they are now just one set but
now the crocodile wants foreign
investment rejecting someone because of
his or her race doesn't seem like a
brilliant economic idea but wait just a
minute because despite all of that the
new president of Zimbabwe might not be
the right man for the job
in a country like this it's easy to find
dark spots on a politician who served
such a crazy dictator and guess what
crocodile did in the 1980s
yes he was the minister of national
security so he would have had something
to do with that genocide that we
mentioned earlier and being the person
who executed genocide doesn't exactly
make you a prime person to run a country
so the question that probably popped
into your mind right now is is there
really someone who can become a true
opposition to this regime and the answer
is absolutely yes
in 2008 there was a political party
called movement the Democratic Change
and surprisingly they beat Mugabe in
those elections yes you totally heard
that right and in a dictatorship like
Zimbabwe this meant a big time political
crisis Mugabe simply couldn't destroy a
political opponents you had such
political capital
but on the other hand you also could
have let him win and finally Mugabe he
came up with a solution he would remain
the president's but he would let his
opponents Morgan Tsvangirai become the
prime minister of course this Prime
Minister remained in power for just four
years during those four years the
Zimbabwe started using the US dollar as
an official currency after the collapse
of their local one that the country it
still remains in dire straits up ways
unemployment rate at ninety percent
this is why it's Fangoria has lost a lot
of political capital so it does seem
that in the next election the crocodile
has all of the chances to win the signs
the army is also going to control the
process and the army sports the
crocodile one thing must be said here
and that is whoever leads this country
next will have a great advantage for it
is impossible to do a worse job than
their predecessor
so now the question becomes do you think
the crocodile will be able to take
Zimbabwe back and make it an african
jewel once again what do you think he's
going to turn into the next Mugabe well
please let us know your answer in the
comment section below and if you want to
know about another African dictator
click on this video to learn about the
history of Egypt also do visit our
friends of the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this video
that were not mine and do not forget to
hit that subscribe button to catch a
brand new video every week and if you
like this video well hit that thumbs up
button and as always I'll see you next
time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice don't forget to check out the
reconsider podcast at reconsider
Mediacom reconsiders a podcast that
challenges you to reconsider your views
by providing context but we don't do the
thinking